l'heure est grave puisqu'il se trame des
choses dans cette émission jean michel
maire je vous le dis vous en faites
partie
oui mettre votre main et sur le capteur
des chroniqueurs en qui j'ai pourtant
une confiance aveugle ferait circuler
des petits mots compromettant pendant
l'émission
je mets pas de stylo ici dans michel
merci votre complice va arriver dans un
instant un pour l'instant je ne les vois
pas son nom art et vous vous voyez de
qui je veux parler
pas du tout jamais jamais je suis blanc
comme neige - titre at il que ces
change-t-il qui veut me nuire il veut
nuire à l'émission ça va trop loin alors
aulas lors des mois qui posent des
questions et jean michel maire présent
malheureusement pour vous et
malheureusement pour votre petit
complices je sais tout je vois tout ça
en temps et forcément j'ai tout vu
chapeau pointu tournée tu dois dans ton
cul
nous avons les images et dans un resto
je lirai le petit papier qui a circulé
alors je vais pas y aller par quatre
chemins
1 je veux savoir qui je veux savoir rémi
semoun il était fou et je veux donc
savoir traficote dans mon dos 1 1
on ne pensait pas mon genre mais
honnêtement dit faites confiance façon
n'en rajoute pas mis en cause en émoi
bien des païens ben là je vous ai
bienvenus or ce n'est pas jean michel
maire non non mais remonter koutoukou
j'ai voulu voir l'hypocrisie mis dans
l'oeil des eaux merci cyril merci à
benjamin castaldi est ce que c'est vous
à tous chanter moins fort le plus bas
puisque c'est vous connaissez pas fait
des dt impossible est ce que vous avez
déjà écrit un papier à quelqu'un jamais
je ne sais pas écrire mais là il est ce
que c'est vous absolument pas par des
mots d'amour
kelly est ce que c'est vous j'ai oublié
l'écriture guy jamais je ne participerai
une conspiration contre vous mourir par
mois isabelle baraille team bas de
conspiration rien si pau crypte ce
registre rien mais bon moi je n'écris
pas je dis tout en face ouais c'est de
toujours mieux fait personne n'a dit non
oui bah oui parce que le coupable
sur wii kurita tous les jours
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr cette île est là alors il est
là où vous avez menti une deuxième fois
vil personnage donné beaucoup jean
michel est ce que oui ou non vous avez
écrit des mots un autre chroniqueur
parfois j'ai vous plaît moi j'écris
parfois j'ai jeudi à valérie l'excédent
syrie mais avant le sens du timing
jean-michel en plus il se fout de vous
fier à l'énoncé avant que je prenne des
sanctions qui pourraient vous mettre mal
les six jeunes dénoncent la rive quoi
qui vous dénoncez tout se passera bien à
moi c'est moi c'est beau non gauche
pourrait être quoi je veux parler a pas
du tout
je chroniqueur a eu l'audace de faire
circuler des dossiers compromettants
dans mon dos quel est son mode
opératoire repartira disent ils pas
partie d'al hommage à l'article ils sont
sévèrement lors d'une émission nous
avons insisté
un mystérieux échangent entre eux jean
michel mr et qui regarde
[Rires]
[Musique]
l'esa
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi ce papier était mort le turc
c'est moi alors donc au secours ok pas
ça scandaleux
ça c'est choquant même la une en
allemand les gens chez eux les
téléspectateurs se disent je tombe de ma
chaise je suis extrêmement déçu que jean
michel maire est là depuis dix ans
comment at il pu faire ça passer un
papier avec une complice oui oui oui
c'est plus grave encore courir nadal oui
malheureusement pour grand corps eric
naulleau sera dans balances ton poste
avec moi dans un instant donné
moyennant un petit billet j'ai réussi à
le faire venir un petit peu avant et il
a toujours en sa possession nemours ce
fameux papier dans la vase jean michel
maire effectivement vous êtes un
bénéfice de 220 morts aussi madame moore
s'est grillé je grille à une table est
applaudie eric naulleau
[Musique]
la fonderie
[Applaudissements]
d'abord rectifier une chose dont je vais
le dire j'ai été qualifiée de complices
je suis la victime dans cette affaire
vous êtes quoi la victime je suis
d'accord a été plutôt la cuc à vingt six
mois ah oui eric et ce n'est pas le seul
papier quoi on a bossé sur voilà jean
michel maire avait l'audace de la
ramener après ce qu'il a fait je
n'hésiterai pas à vous les remettre
également entre émoi les papiers d'hab
je ne les ai pas de vous en avez oui bon
remède débit les rôles et marne avocat
au cas où il m'arriverait quelque chose
je veux que ça soit un peu solennel
l'affairé grave enfin que la plus
nombreuse
eric venet à côté de moi de gagner un
truc ce serait même encore dire que vous
avez créés et eric naulleau
je peux vous dire que les
téléspectateurs alors boîte bien triste
pour moi c'est l'idée n'est pas de leur
une et rôle de cascadeur
c'est jean michel maire qui écrit eric
naulleau eric vous nous dire après si
vous souhaitez porter plainte ou pas
qu'on doive c'est toi qui étais ne va
pas trop loin
tu es allé beaucoup trop loin cela ne va
pas trop vos je vais dire cette lettre
dans un instant qu'eric reste avec nous
bien sûr
juste avant j'ai montré un petit peu
quel personnage de jean michel maire on
était les spectateurs une c'est un ami
parce que par devant vous êtes un amour
mais quand vous êtes avec notre ami
matthieu delormeau
vous êtes en mode catherine et liliane
et après bien sûr je lirai ce papyrus
cadet jean michel mais regardez votre
non
il faut dire qu'il a tu n'as fait tuer
rose l'a sauvée nissan et renault et
nissan
c'est pas les micros on n'est plus bien
sachez qu'on ait privilégié quand on est
ravissante
ben oui et les réponses à nos francs
elle est même pas sûr cela à l'accueil
de cet événement méchant n'y a pas ça
quand le peuple et jean michel maire
avant que je lis qu'il a écrit eric
naulleau pour justifier son manque de
travail aussi jean michel maire passe
son temps à inventer des mythos chez
vous accrochez vous l'heure est grave
regardez
[Musique]
et enfin jean michel maire ne se moque
pas seulement des chroniqueurs in smoke
pas seulement de moi se moque également
des invités jamais réclamée n'a jamais
un grand respect au corps avec son ami
mathieu des ces grains mauvaises
fréquentations regarder les tentations
c'est la nouvelle star vous dis c'est la
number one c'est la chanteuse qui joue
kiffe le plus en ce moment c'est ivan s
les jurés fidélité un je t'aime
idéalisée
[Applaudissements]
nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
non kaunas qui ne connaissent rien on
est d'accord bientôt karim nsc la map
que la plus bankable en ce moment c'est
un carton j'ai vieilli
bah oui bah oui mais au lieu de
critiquer les autres wind river enfin
ouvrir ouvre tout arrêt vous ouvrez vous
à la main au lieu d'ouvrir les autres il
ambitionne aujourd'hui c'est votre fait
déjà pression est ce que je vais dire le
papier dans un objet il ya balanceront
passé sinon c'est à dire le papier vous
avez créé à dolo eric vous voulez que je
lui évidemment et vous nous direz quel
seront les poursuites que vous allez
engager auprès de jean-michel plaignants
n'aura jean-michel censure également
volontairement ses blagues à l'antenne
alors qu'en off
sachez le elles sont bien pire et ce
soir c'est le jeu des vérités je l'avais
tout dévoiler mais n'est pas allée
l'impression oui mr frentzen partir de
maintenant ce sera mr futaba ça a été
mieux j'ai combien de doigts regardez
[Rires]
moi ya plein de gens qui me disent s'ils
n'y a pas de vache est c'est plus
intéressant m'achète une merguez pour
potiche ça rime à rien ça ne se baptise
c'est ça et franchement c'est toutes les
villes taurines qui quittent siegen
je suis des rues sont celles ci seront
peut-être encore volé vous faites
beaucoup de peine
jean-michel je vais donc lire le mot
vous avez envoyé eric naulleau et eric
naulleau nous dira après ce qu'ils
comptent faire parts n 1 va lui une sa
conscience mais j'espère juste une chose
c'est que si vous prenez les bonnes
décisions
j'ose espérer que la justice fera son
travail et j'ai confiance en la justice
française
eric donc c'est jean michel maire qui
écrit ça eric naulleau nouvelles recrues
c'est pour l'accueil
eric je viens de comprendre que la seule
chose que tu as lu dans tpm paix c'est
ton contrat en revanche tu es un très
bon profil
voilà félicitations aux dires et mon cul
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'erreur mais je lui dis fois ça fait
toujours serrés qui est vraiment l'erika
jeep énormément dadu pénale pénale deux
choses qui me prend mal c'est d'abord
qu'il insulte un camarade et ensuite le
le seul demande le subjonctif et d
utiliser de l'indicatif donc non content
de m'insulter il maltraite la langue
française
alors j'ai pas tout compris si je suis
toujours le quartier passé des choses
que tu as lu ouais ouais c'est ça que tu
es alors non mais c'est ça peut être un
détail pour vous mais pour moi ça veut
dire beaucoup les gars veulent se parler
jouer du piano debout parce que c'est un
délinquant global il aurait pu s'en
prendre qu'à moi il a insulté la langue
française d'aujourd'hui cherchent eux le
pardonnerait jean michel baylet mais
merde
jean michel vous avez deux solutions et
érudits ou vous récidivez peut-être qui
prendra la décision d'aller porter
plainte contre vous auprès de ma
personne ou bien
peut-être vous vous excusez vous lui
dites quelque chose où il vraiment ce
que vous pensez lui portait pas sa
rivale au commissariat j'ai dit à mon
cul il a porté à près de vous on va
retirer le nôtre assuré qu' quoi entre
les deux jean-michel via d'autres alors
je vais vous dire moi j'ai pas une
question préférence c'est une question
de justice
sa voiture relais très la droiture est
irréprochable alors jean-michel autres
je vous laisse avec eric naulleau parlez
vous vous avez 20 secondes moi j'ai rien
à dire je suis venu là pour écouter jean
michel des excuses éventuellement à
marathon des excuses l'émission de btp
pas près de commencer je te lis comme
cela il ad'autres tant pis si si vous
incombe à tous les deux non mais dans
une fois c'est quoi il a quand même
d'autres il a quand même tout va bien ça
le truc qui vont verser les papiers
qu'ils auront alors que je vous la fais
à chaque nouvelle base qu'est ce que tu
vas me dire si je dis que je
recommencerai pas atteint je te croirais
pas non je veux des excuses formelles ou
qui ressemble à votre cul les excuses à
mon cul pour commencer déjà
et continua
60 ans jean-michel s'il vous plaît jf
une question du bruit
ciric naulleau porte plainte auprès de
vous quelles seront les sanctions
encourues
je serai extrêmement grave extrêmement
grave je prendrai aller jusqu'à la
révocation par exemple évocation
éventuelles c'est ce que je fais comme
il a parlé de son cul je prendrais son
culte de la mortadelle et je comprends
en tranches horaires appropriés
est-ce que s'il avoue tu t'engages a
vraiment garder ses papiers
ouais si s'excuse-t-il sexuée c'est une
des regrets sincères tu peux aller
brûler des papiers oui je suis maire est
sincère dans la même phrase alors céder
franck téléspectateurs attendent
qu'est ce que vous faites vous rappelle
vous avez dit tu as un très beau profil
félicitations dirait mon cul alors je
voudrais dire que chez les chez moi en
tout cas dans ma famille un certain code
d'honneur qui veut qu'on ne balance pas
aux chefs voilà des infos qu'on peut se
dire entre camarades
alors il a été lancée puisque j'avais
les images a fini dans votre poche bon
moi c'est pareil il a d'autres qu'on
puisse peut-être en tout cas il en est à
l'origine
donc voilà je voudrais que ça soit lui
qui présente ses excuses
[Applaudissements]
avec de l'eau votre réponse très faim se
faire virer c'est à dire qui prépare toi
à ton nom par syrie s'était fait faire
faire un bon mot que de continuer à être
payé pour rien alors je propose que
chacun fasse un pas vers l'autre mais
que le premier pas sera fait par vous
puisque c'est vous qui avez écrit tu as
une phase de reprise et vous n'importe
quel fut le sien oui nous reste une
option
alors je ne ferai pas parler des ricains
mais pourquoi par fierté quand tu sais
je vous le dis je vais avoir le week end
pour décider des sanctions
eric naulleau et charles joseph daul a
pas de téléphone n'était pas vous serez
là tous les deux lundi dans l'émission
bah c'est vous les à l'entrée lundi
18h40 six excuses mais ce qu'ils
apprennent non mais 18h40
venez nous serons peut-être que vous ne
resterez pas longtemps en